on va plus loin avec à mes côtés Bruno
Darroux chroniqueur international à
France 24 bonjour Bruno bonjour Raphaël
dans un instant Marie Roger billot à
directrice du groupe africain
international nous rejoindra il aura
fort à faire en tout cas lui un pour
restaurer la confiance des investisseurs
richissent un acte devenu officiellement
Premier ministre aujourd'hui elle
compose un gouvernement presque à
l'identique de ces prédécesseurs Boris
Johnson et listroth seul la tête change
la sienne donc elle met le plus dur
reste devant lui gagnait la confiance
des Britanniques tout en leur arrachant
des sacrifices écoutés
je reviens de Buckingham Palace où j'ai
accepté la demande de Sa Majesté le Roi
de former un gouvernement son nom
aujourd'hui notre pays fait face à une
profonde crise économique
je veux rendre hommage à ma
prédécesseuse listrus
elle n'avait pas tort de vouloir
relancer la croissance du pays
c'est un objectif noble
et j'admire son énergie pour amener des
changements
mais des erreurs ont été commises
le gouvernement que je dirige ne
laissera pas les prochaines générations
vos enfants et petits-enfants avec une
dette à régler que nous aurions été trop
faible pour payer nous-mêmes
je travaillerai jour et nuit à votre
service
et je comprends aussi que j'ai du
travail à faire
pour restaurer la confiance après tout
ce qui est arrivé
le royaume-uniat s'en sortira pas en
s'affranchissant des lois de
l'attraction par des baisses d'impôts
non financier mais au contraire en
imposant une potion amère pour qui a un
like toute la question d'autant qu'il a
l'image il faut bien dire d'un Premier
ministre des riches richissonnaques
Bruno oui alors bah ce qui est sûr quand
même parce que ça ça fait déjà été
avalisé avec le nouveau ministre des
Finances de l'histoire jumian qui vient
d'être confirmé qui va donc rester
chancelier de l'Échiquier ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'ils étaient déjà quand même
revenus sur la mesure de suppression de
la tranche d'imposition à 45% qui pour
le coup avantageait sérieusement les
plus riches du pays alors oui il a cette
image de Premier ministre des riches
parce que lui-même est riche et sa femme
n'en parlons pas bon il essaye de se
défaire un peu de cette image donc je
pense que ça va être une politique
plutôt globale mais en même temps il a
en quelque sorte promis au Britannique
du sang et des larmes sur le plan
économique car non seulement il faut
faire repartir la machine économique il
faut protéger les Britanniques raconter
à l'inflation mais il a parlé de la
dette qui fait presque 100% du PIB un
peu moins qu'en France et donc il a dit
il faut aussi s'attaquer à ça donc il
faut aussi réduire les dépenses donc
tout ça s'annonce quand même comme une
politique d'austérité à un moment où la
Banque d'Angleterre prévoit une
récession pour l'an prochain bref ça ne
va pas être facile alors que le contexte
politique n'est toujours pas évident
alors sur le fond c'est un homme du
brexit qui nomme d'ailleurs à ses côtés
un vice premier ministre autre partisan
du brexit dominicram qui faisait ainsi
son retour au gouvernement est-ce qu'il
faut pas s'attendre à néanmoins tout de
même un apaisement nos tensions avec le
Royaume-Uni Bruno parce qu'on le sait à
la liste c'est un incarné aussi le
fameux refuge sur le protocole Nord
irlandais par exemple oui mais alors que
va-t-il faire sur le fameux protocole
Nord irlandais ça c'est c'est toute la
question il y aura un apaisement dans
les relations
bilatérales de la France avec la de la
France avec la Grande-Bretagne entre
l'Allemagne et la Grande-Bretagne mais
avec l'Union européenne il y aura quand
même
cette question du protocole Nord
irlandais l'histoire c'était en quelque
sorte engagé déjà ministre des Affaires
étrangères pour le moment c'est pas
réglé mais enfin clairement il aura
affaire le choix soit de vraiment
revenir en arrière de dire à l'Union
européenne écoutez on touche pas au
protocole néerlandais soit d'aller dans
les pas de listress mais là on
repartirait c'est automatique sur un
bras de fer avec l'Union européenne qui
reste sur sa position en disant
britannique écoutez vous avez signé cet
accord c'est un traité c'est signé on ne
revient pas dessus parce que tout d'un
coup vous apercevez que ça crée des
problèmes en Irlande du Nord et on
accueille parmi nous Marie Roger billot
à directrice d'africain internationale
Marie Roger même question qu'à Bruno à
l'instant peut-on et on évoquera après
la personnalité ce qui incarne bien sûr
ichichinack aux yeux de l'électorat
britannique et notamment de
ces minorité visible comme on dit mais
en tout cas sur la question du programme
peut-on
incarner réaliser même le stérilet la
potion amère de l'austérité en faisant
en continu à faire la guerre à Bruxelles
alors je crois que les voix se sont
élevées plusieurs voix se sont déjà
élevées pour leur dire voilà c'est un
nouveau départ reconnaissez que vous
êtes trompé qui a eu beaucoup de
mensonges qu'on ne peut pas se passer du
marché le plus important le mieux
organisé le marché commun le mieux
intégré en disant va le remplacer par
des partenariats individuels
reconnaissez que ça ne va pas peut-être
qu'il faut pas retourner au brexit
remettre à cause de brexit mais vous
pouvez
accepter la main tendue de Bruxelles qui
propose des arrangements des voilà des
partenariats et variés et donc on va
voir ce qu'il va faire le problème c'est
que ici schounac peut-être que Bruno l'a
dit Bruno Régis Luna était l'un des
brexiteurs en chef et que bon maintenant
c'est il a la chance et l'opportunité
parce qu'il y a des changements même au
sein de leur propre
doctrinaire de faire de un type de
révision qui soit en faveur donc de
l'économie britannique qui est commencé
une eau plus mal en ce moment oui ce qui
est très étonnant d'ailleurs c'est que
finalement quand on prend un peu de
recul on s'aperçoit que c'est depuis le
brexit quand même que les choses se
compliquent pour la Grande-Bretagne pour
le moment c'est pas c'est pas une grande
réussite et alors ils n'en parle
absolument pas ces conservateurs parce
que un ils ont été quand même très
mouillés parce que richissounac a été
effectivement un fervent brexitter
Dominique Rabb qui vient d'être nommer
vice-Premier ministre n'en parlons pas
ils ont tous été des soutiennent Boris
Johnson des soutiens du brexit ça
produit quand même des effets hautement
contestables et il en parle pas du tout
un rugissement dans son discours
aujourd'hui pas un mot sur le brexit
comme si c'était acquis alors qu'en fait
ça pose quand même un certain nombre de
problèmes effectivement le le problème
c'est qu'ils ne peuvent pas revenir en
arrière
de manière tout à fait radicale même qui
sont déjà accusés les conservateurs
britanniques de faire des des zigzags
idéologiques auxquels finalement les
électeurs ne comprennent plus grand
chose c'est tout le paradoxe aussi de
richissena que l'on évoquait avec Brunoy
à l'instant 105 carnet la mixité alors
mixité oui bien sûr mais pas social
Marie Roger 1 parce qu'on l'a dit il
vient tout de même d'un milieu favorisé
il a épousé d'ailleurs une milliardaire
il a fait toute sa carrière dans la
banque d'affaires il peut néanmoins de
contribuer à améliorer le sort et le
regard sur les personnes
issues de la diversité et bien chaque
fois qu'il y a ce type de nomination ou
d'élection ça y est on se dit voilà ça
va avoir un impact magique on a vu ça
pour Barack Obama et je me souviens on
avait invité
Martin Luther King le fils du fameux à
Paris à la même période et les gens
posaient la question alors le racisme
est fini alors aux États-Unis c'est on
est passé
à l'époque
et on a bien vu que
non seulement c'est pas le cas il y a
mais il y a même eu un boomerang
c'est-à-dire s'il y avait pas eu Barack
Obama on n'aurait pas eu Donald Trump il
y a des gens qui sont sans réaction en
réaction et aussi chaque fois qu'il y a
une personnalité comme ça qui est nommée
issue de la minorité nommé à des postes
ce genre on s'attend à ce qu'il fasse
des choses pour sa communauté ça dit ça
communauté Satan ce qu'il fasse des
choses pour c'est exactement ce qu'il
faut pas faire parce que c'est abstenu
de faire d'ailleurs Barack Obama ça a
été reproché complètement il était je
dirais des mêmes plus en retrait que
c'est sa vie était quelqu'un d'autre il
a il voulait surtout pas passer pour un
communautariste et c'est la même chose
aussi
qu'on va vérifier son acte c'est tout à
fait différent mais les sociologues nous
disent que ce genre de nomination n'a
pas d'impact
visible et
du parti conservatoire le président du
Parti conservateur et lui-même issu de
de la d'ailleurs il figure aussi au
gouvernement mais sans sans portefeuille
la ministre de l'intérieur avec des pour
vous pourtant très durs à la vie
d'ailleurs démissionné dans les derniers
jours du cabinet list Trust est issu de
la diversité donc richissou n'applume il
y a une volonté des conservateurs
d'appareils modernes quelques années de
l'appareil du haut du Parti conservateur
de faire ça et avec un certain succès
bon ce riches ounaque il faut noter
quand même celle-là quand même pas du
tout le même impact que l'élection de
Barack Obama c'est-à-dire que au
Royaume-Uni ça a été considéré bon comme
voilà une nomination
certes oui qui qui fait plaisir à faire
qu'il n'a pas réussi à l'emporter face à
l'Histoire s'il y a un mois et demi
ce qui a joué contre lui dit certains
commentateurs outre-manches au mois de
juillet quand le processus électoral
vraiment avait concerné non seulement
les députés mais aussi les quelques
200000 membres du Parti conservateur
c'est qu'elle avait beaucoup de ces noms
du Parti conservateur qui était un peu
des voilà des mâles blancs de plus de 50
ans vivant en zone rurale je caricature
un peu mais voilà tu dis bon faut un
indien quand même dans notre partie ça
le fait pas là on n'est pas allé jusque
là parce qu'il était le seul candidat
déclaré avoir le nombre de soutiens
suffisants donc il a été automatiquement
uniquement par l'appareil des députés en
quelque sorte consacrés Premier ministre
on n'a pas demandé leur avis aux
adhérents du parti conservateur mais moi
je parlais dans l'ensemble de la société
britannique je pense que ça n'a rien à
voir parce que alors à ce thé
britannique bien sûr il y a du racisme
bien sûr il y a des problèmes mais ce
n'est quand même pas tout à fait la même
chose qu'aux États-Unis le fameux
communautarisme à l'anglaise est quand
même bien installée lui-même est
considéré d'ailleurs comme un British
Indian puisqu'en fait il est né en
Angleterre sa famille est originaire
effectivement dan après
au Kenya en Afrique de l'Est donc voilà
pour pour les Britanniques c'est
beaucoup moins quelque chose de de
fortement symbolique que de l'été
l'élection de Barack Obama quand même
mais il y a eu quand même du
volontarisme du côté des conservateurs
c'est depuis Cameron qui a décidé David
Cameroun donc l'ancien Premier ministre
qui a décidé de faire
voilà on va retenir deux choses de lui
le brexit et puis aussi l'inclusion des
minorités dans le Parti conservateur et
qui avait décidé de les mettre à des
postes gagnables voilà de députés etc
mais cela dit ce sont les travaillistes
malgré leur passé leur histoire
antisémite qui ont le plus de de d'élus
de
la diversité comme on dit
lui il a été il est devenu premier
ministre parce qu'il correspondait aux
normes du Parti conservateur c'est pas
ça n'a rien à voir avec son être cité et
c'est toujours l'erreur qu'on fait quand
on se dit voilà voilà il va avoir si
elle impacte on pourrait dire qu'on y
fait un peu moins attention tellement
il donne le sentiment effectivement de
faire partie tellement de l'élite voilà
Oxford l'université aux États-Unis enfin
bon
parti conservateur n'est pas sûr qu'il
aurait été
43% quand même avec contre les stress on
va dire un mot aussi du Soudan à on
manifestait aujourd'hui en signe de
protestation un an jour pour jour après
le putsch qui a mis fin à la présence
des civils au pouvoir un manifestant est
mort renversé par un véhicule militaire
écoutez ce que disait d'ailleurs
quelques-uns des participants à cette
manifestation
on manifeste pour dire une chose on ne
veut pas de compromis politique on ne
veut pas de partenariat avec pas de
négociation et pas de solutions
politiques on n'est pas là pour discuter
du putsch on veut le renverser et pour
ça on est prêt à payer le prix même de
notre vie le peuple soudanais meurt de
faim donc il n'accepte rien de tout ça
on sera là le 25 octobre le 30 octobre
tout le monde a manifester dans toutes
les villes du Soudan le régime du
boucher abdelfatal et des forces de
sécurité va tomber
à la tête du Conseil dit de transition
mais a-t-il encore d'ailleurs autre les
oripeaux de la transition la question
est permise m'a érogène l'intérêt en
tout cas de ces manifestations c'est que
elles évitent qu'on oublie le Soudan et
pour le régime de tomber dans une forme
de normalisation finalement tout à fait
et ça c'est assez
admirable de la part des Soudanais ça
fait un an qu'ils sont ils manifestent
presque tous les jours c'est-à-dire il y
a les manifestations visibles dans la
rue etc mais ils sont extrêmement
organisés sur le terrain à rédigé des
chartes comment doit être un
gouvernement civil et comment on doit
être une vers la démocratie etc il y a
une mobilisation permanente et là on
voit aussi l'histoire des militaires les
militaires c'est une impasse c'est une
impasse et ils veulent surtout pas ceux
du soudain comme ceux d’ailleurs on a
quelques clins d'oeil ils ne veulent
surtout pas partir parce que ils
perdrait les avantages économiques
qu'ils ont sur la société
soudaine sur l'appareil Soudani c'est
tout ce qu'il est les intéresse en fait
et également l'autre souci qu'ils ont
c'est que comme ils ont commis beaucoup
beaucoup d'exactions ils ont peur d'un
tribunal un tribunal d'exception ils ont
peur de rendre des comptes donc ils ont
absolument rien à l'esprit ou un schéma
pour rendre le pouvoir et on a dans
cette mobilisation ils sont quand même
soutenus aussi toujours par les mêmes le
Qatar le la Turquie etc mais ils ont
quand même aussi la pression
internationale pour rendre le pouvoir
c'est l'étouffoir contre la transition
démocratique Bruno oui enfin ils sont
effectivement dans une position quand
même très dure et on fasse aussi on
entendit les manifestants en fait c'est
pas de pas de discussion possible avec
ces gens-là ils sont allés trop loin
puisqu'en fait ils ont un peu brisé
l'esprit de la révolution de 2019 qui a
chassé certes au bar et le Béchir enfin
c'était aussi pour un peu chasser les
militaires du pouvoir alors ils ont fait
semblant en fait de gouverner un peu
avec les civils pendant deux ans et puis
après précisément un an le général
alburane voilà il est il les a tous
arrêtés etc donc là on a entendu la
détermination de ces manifestants qui
disent non mais il y a plus de
discussion possible il y a plus de
compromis possibles il faut juste qu'il
dégage maintenant ces militaires pour
retrouver l'esprit de cette révolution
de 2019 sinon en fait quelque part c'est
l'armée qui revient on revient on
retourne à la dictature militaire qui a
connu le pays depuis l'indépendance et
ce n'est juste pas possible alors en
même temps c'est pas très bon signe
parce que ça veut dire que les
ne vont pas baisser et on peut constater
aussi que un an après ce putsch du
général Alboran et bien il n'arrive pas
à imprimer et avoir quelques soutiens
dans la société c'est proche de rien
surtout
faire consensuel alors
l'an prochain pour voir pas franchement
comment elle pourrait se tenir donc
merci merci Marie Roger merci Bruno
c'était on va plus loin on se retrouve
dans moins de 3 minutes pour un nouveau
journal rester avec nous
[Musique]
c'est l'heure de politique